네 안녕하세 빌사남 있니다 어 제가
오늘은 퇴폐업소 명도 했던 썰을 좀
풀 건데 한 13년 전 쯤이에요 제가
20대 초반에 처음 이일을 할 때
있었던 일입니다 임차인이 건물 내부를
못 들어오겠어요 건물 앞에 커피숍에서
만나자라고 해서 좀 되게 좀 의심이
많이 갔습니다 그러다가 갑자기
건물주한테 통지서가 날라왔어요
강남구청에서 지금 폐 업소로
적발됐다이 임차인을 내보내지 않으면
과태료를 부과하겠다라는 그런 통지서가
날아왔습니다 그때 당시 건물주가
해외에 있었거든요 카톡으로 연락이
와서 이제 어떡하냐라고 해서 제가 그
임차인을 만나러 갔습니다 연락드린
다음에 만나러 갔는데 일단은 제가
사실 키가 170 공개 제가 키가
그렇게 크진 않지만 어 그분 같은
경우에는 키가 굉장히 컸어요 한 거의
진짜 느낌상 한 180 후반 거의
190 가까이 됐고 그리고 그날
굉장히 추운 날이었는데 나시를 입고
왔어요네 나시를 입고 오고 여기
팔뚝에 운신이 되게 크게
있으시더라고요네 저를 만나서 첫
마디가 너 죽고 싶냐 했어요 어 너
죽고 싶냐 내가 권리금 4천만 원
주고 들어왔는데 네가 뭔데 나가라
말아야냐 그 자리에서 정말 욕이라는
욕은 다 먹었습니다 건물주한테 똑바로
얘기해라 난 절대 나갈 생각이 없다
예 이런 식으로 거의 협박을 엄청
듣고 이제 헤어진 다음에 이거를
내보내지 않으면 건물주한테 과태료를
부과하기 때문에 계속 이제 내용
증명을 좀 보낼 수밖에 없었어요 내용
증명을 보낼 때마다 전화와서 야이
땡땡아 너 뭐 어 너 진짜 너 가만
안 두겠다고 이제 계속 하고 그
심지어는 새벽에 진짜 문자를 어떻게
하냐면 너 칼 맞아 봤냐고 문자가
왔어요 새벽에 새벽 한
시쯤에
그래서 진짜 제가 뭐 지금은 이렇게
좀 뭐 웃으면서 얘기하고 하지만 그때
당시 20대 초반이었는데 일한지 이제
얼마 안 됐을 때 그때는 정말 너무
하루하루가 힘들었고 어디 갈 때마다
막 이렇게 주변을 살피면서 다니고 막
그랬었거든요 그렇게 되게 좀 한
3개월 정도 그렇게 좀 있다가 마지막
이제 고소장을 보낼 쯤이었어요 이제
정 안 나간다 그래서 고소장을 보낼
쯤에 갑자기 이제 전화가 와서 일단
욕을 하시
한번 만나자라고 해서 거기 안에서
도저히 못 만나 겠는 거야 너무
무서워서 그래서 거기 앞에 커피숍에
사람 제일 많은 커피숍에 만나자고
했어요 만나기 전에 뭘 했냐면 건물
주원한테 이사비용 정도는 좀 챙겨
주자라고 해서 건물주를 설득한 다음에
케를 받아 놓은 상태였어요 그래서
만나자고 한 다음에 그 커피숍을
갔는데 혼자 안 나오시더라고요 거의
한 다섯 명 정도 이렇게 머리 되게
짧으신 분들 다섯 분 정도 같이 와서
얘기를 했죠 얘기를 하고 임차인을
만나자마자 어 이사 비용 주겠다라고
하면 그 이상을 얘기합니다 일단은
제가 너무 건물주의 편이다 얘기는 안
하고 그분의 편인 것처럼 얘기를
했어요 아 이거 사장님 소송하면 이게
어찌됐든 불법적인 요소기 때문에
무조건 소송해서진다 예 소송해지는 거
플러스 뭐 변호사비 그리고 기타
비용들 다 합치면 손해가 너무 심하다
그 임차인을 생각하면서 좀 많이
얘기해 줬던 거 같아요 그리고
마지막으로 내가 건물주한테 이사비용
정도 얘기해 보겠다 그게 한 300만
원 정도였거든요 이사비용 받고
나가는게 지금 사장님한테 최선의
선택인 거 같다 진짜 진심으로
말씀드리니까 아 그럼 생각해
보겠다라고 하고 한 10분 정도
있다가 아 그럼 그렇게 하겠다
건물주한테 지금 대신 확답을 얻어
달라 뭐 이미 다 허락을 받았으니까
예 그래서 저 전화해가지고 어
얘기하니까 이제 오케이 되겠다 그래서
그 300만 원 주고 내보냈습니다 좀
저한테는 좀 되게 무서운 일이었고
그런 일이긴 했지만 좀 좀 되게 큰
경험을 했던 거 같아요 그래서
이것처럼 임차인을 명도 한다라는 거는
굉장히 좀 쉽지 않은 일이기도 해요
물론 이제 쉽게 나갈 수도 있지만 예
그리고 특히 주택보다는 상가 같은
경우가 되게 좀 내 이렇게
명도하고네 그래서 여러분들 나중에
임차인을 하실 생각이라고 하면 최초
계약일 어 최초 계약일 확인하신
다음에 갱신 요구권이 어느 정도
있는지 지금 판례 중에 갱신 요구권
이후에 이제 내보내도 권리금을 인정해
줘야 된다는 그런 판례도 있어요 제가
봤을 때 제일 괜찮은 명도는 내용
증명 한 번 안 보내고 잘 협의해서
이렇게 내보내는 명도가 저는 제일
좋은 명도하고 생각하거든요 여러분들이
좀 명도할 때 그런 부분을 좀 많이
신경 써 가지고 잘 협의해서 명도를
진행하셨으면 좋겠습니다 오늘은 어
이렇게 좀 임차의 명도에 대해서 좀
설명을 드렸고요 태표 업소 명도 한게
20대 초반이었고 되게 무섭기도 하고
그랬지만 그걸로 인해서 좀 더
배우는게 많고 좀 더 되게 단단해진
그런 요소이지 않을까네 그렇게 생각을
합니다네 그래서 오늘 명도 이야기는
여기까지 하고요 어 여러분들 다음
시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다